Fumio Kishida has edged out three other candidates to win the LDP's leadership race,...
...a race that determined not only who will steer the conservative party...
...but also the person expected to become Japan's next prime minister.
That's why Kishida spoke of national priorities in his victory speech.
Japan is still facing a national crisis.
We must continue our efforts against COVID-19 with utmost determination.
Beyond that, there are many important issues related to Japan's future...
...such as new capitalism, the realization of a free and open Indo-Pacific...
...and measures against the declining birth rates.
Fumio Kishida is a former foreign minister and a former banker.
Seen as as consensus builder,...
...his policies sit comfortably in the center of his political family.
The 64-year-old has promised to maintain the Central Bank's stimulus injections...
...and propose a massive spending plan to help the post-pandemic economy.